[VOCALIZING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
(SINGING) Freedom to love--
In this class, I want to share
with you my writing process
and what comprises a song.
(SINGING) Go down,
Moses, way down,
Moses, go down to every land.
When I start a song,
most of my songs
start with a mumble
track, and what
I'm doing- the only
thing I'm worried about
is the melody and the
structure of the song.
The bridge is like
more rapid fire lyrics,
building tension, and then
landing again at our chorus.
[PLAYING PIANO]
I just wrote a brand
new song called, "Free."
I start with the melody--
[VOCALIZING]
(SINGING) Let it wash
through the valley, soar
to the mountains, fall
in the deepest blue sea.
What unique thing do you want
to put out into the world?
Whether you want to make a
moment or start a movement,
this song writing
class is for you.
(SINGING) We'll see.
Rain down freedom, rain
down 'til we're all free.